The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
MICHAEL SHORT: Today I
want us to go more in-depth
into the photon
interactions with matter,
and we're going to bring
the theory back to something
that we can actually
start to use in doing
shielding calculations.
If you want to find out
how much of this material
do I need to shield
this much gammas,
we're going to answer
that question today.
First I want to
start off, again,
with Compton scattering
because I messed up
a couple of the energy
things from last time.
I got excited due to an
energetic coincidence
between the photo peak and
the continent of our banana
spectrum and one of the
examples in the book.
So I'm going to
correct that now,
and we'll go through in
more mathematical detail
why that wasn't
the case, and what
the actual quirk of
physics is because there
is a constant energy
thing here that I
want to highlight to you guys.
So skipping ahead on the
photoelectric effect,
which I think was similar,
to review Compton scattering.
It's the same thing that we
saw between two particles,
except now one of
them is a photon.
And like I said, on the next
homework, after quiz one,
you guys will be doing
the balance between energy
and momentum, because the
photons don't really have mass,
in order to figure out
what's the relationship
between the incoming
energy of the photon,
the outgoing energy
of the photon,
and the recoil energy
of the electron.
And so these are
the relationships
we were showing last time.
It is an interesting
quirk of physics
that the wavelength
shift itself does not
depend on the energy of
the photon coming in.
As you can see, it just depends
on the angle that it scatters
at and a bunch of constants,
where that m right there stands
for mass of the electron.
Now that wavelength shift--
while that wavelength shift
does not depend on the energy
of the incoming photon--
the recoil energy does.
You can see it depends on
both the energy and the angle.
And the incoming energy
of the photon equals h nu.
And to give that quick
primer on photon things,
I want to show you guys
here why that's the case.
So even if you have a
constant wavelength shift
that might give you a
non-constant energy shift.
So even though in this
constant scattering formula,
the wavelength shift only
matters with the angle,
the energy shift
actually depends
on the angle and the incoming
energy of the photon.
So now let's look at a
couple of limiting cases.
So as we have e of the
photon equals h nu goes to 0,
what does t approach?
The recoil energy
of the electron.
Let's just do out the formula.
This recoil energy
equals h nu, which
is the energy of the
incoming gamma times 1
minus cosine theta over mc
squared over h nu plus 1
minus cosine theta.
As h nu approaches
0, what happens here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHAEL SHORT: Yeah.
H nu goes to 0.
This fraction goes to infinity.
And this goes to 0.
Hopefully that's an
intuitive explanation.
If the incoming
photon has 0 energy,
it can transfer 0
energy to the electron.
Now the more interesting case.
What happens now as e
gamma approaches infinity,
as the photon gets higher
and higher in energy?
AUDIENCE: T just
approaches h nu.
MICHAEL SHORT: T
approaches almost h nu.
I actually want to do a quick
calculation without doing
all the limit math.
Let's say we had
energy of the gamma
was 1 GeV, an
extremely high energy.
So all we'd plug
in-- and let's say
we wanted to find out
what's the maximum energy
of this recoil electron.
And this is something
I want to ask you guys.
I can't remember.
Yesterday did we say that
t is a maximum at theta
equals pi or pi over 2?
What did we say yesterday?
AUDIENCE: Pi over 2.
MICHAEL SHORT: Interesting.
It's pi, actually.
The case where you have the
largest energy transfer--
and sorry for not
catching that--
is just like in a
nuclear collision,
if the photon were
to back scatter,
it transfers the maximum
energy to the electron.
So the analogy here
is, like, perfect.
Between two particles
hitting and between a photon
and a particle hitting,
the maximum energy
is when theta equals pi.
And let's actually plug
that in to find out why.
If we say t max equals h nu--
depends on the electron coming
in--
1 minus cosine theta over
mc squared over h nu plus 1
minus cosine theta.
At theta equals pi, cosine
theta goes to minus 1,
and so then that
also goes to minus 1.
And so this becomes 2h nu over
mc squared over h nu plus 2.
And so that without worrying
about the numerator,
especially in the limit of
very high energy photons,
you can see that that actually
maximizes the recoil energy
of the electron.
The reason we're harping so
much on this recoil energy
of the electron is because
that's what we measure.
So when we look at
our banana spectrum,
you're not measuring the
energy of the photon.
You're measuring
the recoil energy
of the electron and
the ionization cascade
that happens as all
those electrons smash
into each other, creating
electron whole pairs, which
are counted as current.
If you guys remember from
last class-- in fact,
I'll just bring up
the blackboard image
because we can do that.
So I took a picture of
the board yesterday,
photon interactions Part 1.
There it is.
We'll just use the screen as
a bigger blackboard for now.
So if you guys
remember, let's say
a gamma ray comes in and
causes a Compton scatter
event or a photoelectric
emission, or whatever.
It doesn't matter which process.
And it liberates an electron,
either by scattering off of it
or just getting absorbed
and ejecting it.
Or it doesn't really
matter how, but it creates
this electron hole pair.
That electron right here
has this recoil energy,
which depends on theta,
the angle that it scatters
and the incoming.
Energy and that
electron's going to keep
moving in this
material, knocking
into other electrons
very, very efficiently so
that most of the energy
of that electron recoil
actually gets counted as
other electrons being freed.
We're going to go over on--
well, next Friday-- electron
nuclear interactions,
including what's the
probability in energy transfer
when electrons slam
into each other
or when ions slam into
electrons or each other?
So let me go back to the slides.
And so this maximum, as
this approaches infinity,
this actually approaches a
value of h nu minus .255 MeV
Just to do the quick calculation
to give a numerical example,
if I plug in theta
equals pi and h mu
equals 1 gig electron
volt, or 1,000 MeV.
And can anyone remind me what is
mass of the electron c squared?
What's the rest mass
of the electron?
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHAEL SHORT: Right.
While I'm usually against
memorizing anything--
because that's what books
and the internet are for--
this is one of those
quantities that I
want on the tip of your
tongue as nuclear engineers.
You should remember what the
rest mass of the electron
is because a lot
of our quantities
are calculated based upon it.
For example, this ratio--
what was it, h nu
over MeC squared--
gives you the energy
the photon in terms
of the number of
electron rest masses,
which is a useful
quantity in itself.
So why don't I plug
all this stuff in.
So we have .511 over 1,000 plus
2 flipped over the x-axis times
2 times h nu.
And we get-- so that
t becomes 999.745 MeV.
Interestingly enough, 1,000
MeV, our ingoing photon,
minus that equals
that right there.
So that's the interesting
quirk of physics
is as the photon
increases in energy,
the maximum amount of energy
that it can leave with--
or sorry, the minimum
amount of energy
the photon can leave with,
or the maximum amount
it can impart to an
electron approaches
.255 MeV or the photon
energy minus that.
What do you guys notice
about that number?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHAEL SHORT: That's right.
It's exactly half the
rest mass of the electron.
So as your photons hit
the GeV range and above,
they can all leave
with half the rest
mass of the electron
of energy, which
means you have more and more
energy able to be transferred
in a given Compton
scatter as the photon gets
higher and higher in energy.
So for the limit of
low energy, the photons
basically bounce off without
transferring much energy
at all.
And the higher in
energy the photon gets,
the higher percentage of
that maximum transfer can be.
So that's what I wanted
to clarify from last time.
It was an interesting
coincidence
that our photo peak
and our Compton edge
were pretty close to
that number apart.
But one MeV isn't
quite infinity.
But it is pretty close.
That difference right there,
what does that come out to?
Before I say something stupid,
I'll just calculate it.
1.241.
It's like 0.218 MeV, so we're
already most of the way there.
So once you reach,
like, 10 or 100 MeV,
you're pretty much
at that limit.
And so what that tells
you is that the distance
between a photo peak and
its corresponding Compton
edge for high energy photons
is going to be half the rest
mass of the electron.
Once you get to lower
and lower energies,
that distance will
start to shrink.
I'm sorry, other way around.
That distance will
start to grow.
And I have a few examples
I want to show you.
But first, in order
to understand these,
now I want to get into
the part I told you
we'd get to yesterday,
which is what's
the probability that a
Compton scatter happens
at a certain angle?
And this polar plot
explains it pretty well.
In the limit of
really low photons,
like .01 MeV or 10
keV photons, you
can see that this forward
scattering to an angle of 0,
or back scattering
to an angle of 180--
there's a 180 that's blocked
by an axis right there--
they're almost the same.
So forward and back
scattering, there's
not really that much of a big
difference in probability.
So if we were going to start
graphing theta of this Compton
scatter as a function of the--
going to introduce this new
quantity, this angularly
dependent cross-section.
Before we were giving
you cross- sections
in the form of just
sigmas, like sigma Compton.
Now we're actually
telling you what's
the probability of that
interaction happening
in this certain angle?
So it's called the
differential cross-section,
and you can have all sorts of
differential cross-sections,
like energy differential
cross-sections,
angle differential
whatever have you.
So if we try and graph what dpes
the shape of this look like,
this polar plot on a more
understandable graph,
we can see that the
probability is pretty high.
Let's just call that a
relative probability of 1.
And as we trace
around this circle,
that value gets lower and
lower until we hit 90 degrees,
or pi over 2, at which point
it starts to pop back up
almost to its original value.
So this was for a 10 keV photon.
Now let's take a
different extreme example.
We have a 3 MeV
photon right here.
And it's that long dashed curve,
so that one here in the center.
So we can see that the relative
probability of 0 degrees
is the same.
And if we trace
around to 180, we're
almost at the origin, which
tells us that, for 3 MeV,
it starts off the same and
quickly drops really far down.
What that means is that what's
called forward scattering
is preferred.
So up on this board,
we were talking
about what's the maximum energy
that a photon can transfer,
which is always in the
back scattering case.
The other part to note is
that that back scattering
probability gets lower and
lower as the photon gets
higher and higher in energy.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So it's
that basically saying,
since we said forward
scattering [INAUDIBLE]
as the energy gets
higher, you just
have a harder chance
of it interacting.
MICHAEL SHORT: Exactly.
Yeah.
The cross-section
value, well, yeah, it
goes down as you
increase in energy.
So a total forward scatter, if
you had a true forward scatter
where theta equals 0,
I'll call that a miss.
It means that, because
we saw on this formula
up here when theta equals 0,
there is no energy transfer.
Nothing.
And so yeah, that would
be to me like a miss.
If that angles ever
so slightly above 0,
then there is some
scattering, but there's
very little energy transfer.
But that smaller
energy transfer becomes
more likely when the photon
goes higher in energy.
These are these sorts of
cause and effect relationships
I want you guys to be
able to reason out.
If I were to give you a polar
plot of this differential
cross-section with
angle and energy,
I'd want you to be able to
reproduce this and tell me
what's really going on.
If we fill in one of
the ones in between--
let's go with 0.2 MeV, this
sort of single dashed line--
you can see that the
probability of back scattering
is somewhere between the
3 MeV and the 10 keV.
Yeah, Luke?
AUDIENCE: Back scattering
refers to the photon going back.
MICHAEL SHORT: That's right.
Back scattering refers to the
photon going back, which means
this situation,
where the difference
in angle between the
incoming and outgoing photon
is pi, 180 degrees, which means
it just turns around and moves
the other way.
Right.
So that dashed line right
there would follow something
like this at-- what did we say?
0.2 MeV.
The form, the full form of
this cross-section right
here is referred to as the
Klein-Nishina cross-section.
And it has been derived by
quantum electro dynamics, which
I will not derive for you now.
But there are plenty
of derivations
online if that's
your kind of thing.
And I had to make a
trade-off in this class
of how deep do we go into
each concept versus how
many concepts do we teach?
And I'm going for the
latter because if there
is any course that's
supposed to give you
an overview of
nuclear, it's 22.01.
There will be plenty of time
for quantum in 22.02 and beyond,
should you want.
At any rate, this is
the general form of it.
And what this
actually tells you is
that as the energy of
the photon increases,
the effect of that angle will--
you guys'll have to work that
out on a homework problem.
I just remembered.
I want to stop
stealing your thunder
and giving away
half the homework.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: How does [INAUDIBLE]?
MICHAEL SHORT: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --the quantity
D sigma D omega.
MICHAEL SHORT: The
quantity D sigma D
omega says let's say you have a
photon coming in at our x-axis.
You've got an electron here.
What's the probability that
I'm going to scatter off
into some small area d omega?
So in some small d theta d
phi, or some small sine theta,
d theta d phi, into an
element of solid angle.
I should probably
draw that smaller
to be a little more
differential looking.
So gammas are going to
scatter off in all directions.
But this d sigma
d omega tells you
what's the probability that it
goes through that little patch?
AUDIENCE: And then that omega is
also a function of [INAUDIBLE]??
MICHAEL SHORT: So that omega has
some component of theta in it
and some component of phi in it.
Since it's a solid
angle, it depends
on both the angle of rotation
and the angle of inclination,
which we call theta and phi.
Now to get from this to the
regular cross-section you're
used to, you can integrate
over all angles omega
of the differential
cross-section,
and you'll get the regular
total cross-section, which
is just what is the probability
of Compton scattering,
full stop.
If you wanted to
know, then, what's
the probability of Compton
scattering into this angle,
it sounds kind of boring, right?
Why do we care about the angle?
Anyone bored yet?
You can raise your hands.
Be honest.
Interesting.
OK.
Well, I'm going to tell you
why it's not boring because I
don't think you're honest.
You can actually, if you know
the angle at which a Compton
photon scatters into--
actually I want to
leave that stuff up--
there is a pretty much
one to one relation
between the energy and
the angle of scattering,
which means that let's say
you have a cargo container.
I'm sorry.
You don't have a
cargo container.
You have a cargo ship full
of tons and tons of these
stacked up cargo containers.
Has anyone actually ever
seen one of these before?
OK.
In case not, I'm going
to do something dangerous
and go to the internet.
And hopefully the search
for cargo container
doesn't come up with
something disgusting.
Oh, look at that.
How about cargo container ship?
Yeah.
OK.
You got one of these, right?
And your detector
goes off, and it just
says there is something
radioactive that
shouldn't be here.
How do you find
out which container
it's in without
taking the ship apart?
Interesting problem, huh?
Do you just kind of look-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do you
kind of like shield
certain angles [INAUDIBLE]?
MICHAEL SHORT: That's one way.
You could mask off the ship
and move your detector around,
and then do it for the
other two dimensions.
So that will get you
there, but slowly.
How do you do it quickly?
Well, you do it with the
Klein Nishina cross-section.
If you know the relationship
between the energy
and the angle of
a Compton scatter,
you take two detectors,
Detector 1, Detector 2,
and you form what's
called a Compton camera.
This is awesome because
with two detectors,
you can pinpoint the location of
a radiation source by knowing--
let's say you had a gamma
ray that entered Detector 1.
So you have your
initial e gamma.
And you get a spectrum.
Let's draw a couple of spectra.
I'm going to use
different colors
so I can make them bigger.
This will be intensity
and this will be energy.
So we have our blue
Detector 1, and we
have some spectrum
for Detector 1
where we get the photo peak
of the gamma at e gamma.
And this time, you don't
see every possible angle.
You only see whatever angle you
get that Compton scatter at.
Or you might see a whole
bunch of different angles.
Never mind.
So you're going
to see the Compton
edge in this whole
continuum of things.
And so you know that whatever
energy this corresponds
to means that theta equals pi.
That energy corresponds
to theta equals 0.
And you know that there's
a source somewhere in here.
Now let's say that photon
scatters out of Detector 1
and into Detector 2.
In this case, you've
no longer just
know that you have a
source of some sort.
You'll end up with
a certain photo peak
corresponding to this e
gamma prime, the only energy
that can Compton scatter in
the direction from Detector 1
to Detector 2,
because you have now
determined the angles between
the line between the detectors
and the detector at the source.
So then you get a photo peak and
the corresponding Compton edge
for your e gamma prime.
Your e gamma prime, that tells
you the angle that it came off
of for your first interaction.
So that is your source angle.
So what that means is that
by using these two angles,
you've now pinpointed your
source to lie somewhere
on these two cones projected
back on one of the two points
where those cones at
that angle intersect.
This is something I want
you to try and think
about and work out on your own.
But it's really cool to explain
this because with one detector,
you know that there's
a source somewhere,
and you know generally
where to point.
With two detectors
and energy resolution,
the energy of the photo
peak of the second event
tells you what the angle
of the first event was.
And this way, if
you know what source
you're looking for from
the first photo peak,
and you know what
angle you're looking
for from the Compton
scattered photons photo
peak, because they
have those, then you
know not only what the
source is, but where it is.
And you know which
container should
take a part to start looking.
So this is why we care
about angle, because there's
actual, real ways of using
this to your advantage
to solve some pretty insane
problems, like which container
would that be in.
Who's starting to get the
general idea behind a Compton
camera, or who would
like another explanation?
Anyone?
I asked two questions.
So who would like
another explanation?
Yeah, OK.
The idea here is with
just one detector,
all you know is whether
or not there is a source.
The only information
you're getting
is its photo peak and
Compton edge and bowl.
And so you know the
identity of the source.
Maybe it's cobalt
60 or something.
But you don't know where it is.
By making a second
measurement, you
can then determine
where on the Compton
spectrum of the
first measurement
does the photon lie.
So by saying OK, the
photo peak corresponds
to this energy,
which corresponds
to some certain angle that
this had to scatter off of.
So then you know
what this angle is.
You've determined theta.
AUDIENCE: Is that the
same theta that you just
drew as theta angle?
MICHAEL SHORT: Yes.
OK.
Angle.
You've then
determined this angle
because you know the
incoming path of the photon,
and you now know
the outgoing path,
which means you know angle.
So if you know the line
between these two detectors,
and your photo pick lines
up with your first Compton
spectrum's angle, you then
look at that angle back.
You also have to sweep around
in the other direction, which
means you end up with a
cone of possible locations.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How do you
know that the photons
that get to the second scatter
from inside the first one?
MICHAEL SHORT: There
can be only a couple
of things that
could happen, right?
You could have another
direct photon just
shoot into Detector
2, in which case
you'll just get a little
bit of photo peak.
But we know to expect
that, so we can ignore it.
We're specifically
looking for the photo peek
coming from Detector 1.
AUDIENCE: So they wouldn't
just go in the air
and do Compton
scatter [INAUDIBLE]??
MICHAEL SHORT: They would,
which gives the perfect pretext
to bring up the cross-sections
for these processes.
So I'm going to skip
ahead a little bit
and start getting into what do
the actual cross-sections look
like for Compton scattering,
photoelectric, and pair
production?
All of them have to
do with the electron
density of the material.
The more electrons
in the way, the more
you get these events happening.
So yes, you will get
Compton scatters in the air
because air contains electrons
and they do Compton scatter.
But air is not
very dense, so you
will get comparatively less.
So let's say that adds
a little bit of noise
on the bottom, which is like
any detector spectrum we've ever
seen.
There's always noise from
all sorts of other processes
we're not looking for.
So now let's start
to look at what
the general energy and z ranges
of each of these effects are.
And we're going to
recreate one of the plots
that I showed you at the
beginning of yesterday's class.
So let's make a graph
of energy of the photon
and z of the material.
And we want to try to map
out where the following three
processes are dominant.
So tau, our
photoelectric effect.
C, which we'll call
our Compton scattering.
And kappa, which we'll
call pair production.
And these cross-sections do
give us relative probabilities
as a function of the energy
of the photon and the medium
they're going through, along
with the actual density,
that something's
going to happen.
So let's look at
the form of these.
The cross-section for the
photoelectric effect scales
with z to the 5th.
Do you think that
photoelectric effect
will be more likely for
low z or high z materials?
AUDIENCE: High.
MICHAEL SHORT: High
z materials, right.
So we know we're going to
be in the top half area.
And it scales with one
over energy to the 7/2.
So do you think
this will be most
likely with low or high energy?
AUDIENCE: Low.
MICHAEL SHORT: So lower energy.
So we're going to fill in
our photoelectric somewhat.
Oh, I'm sorry.
So we know it's going to
be in this part of the z.
We know it's going to be in
this part of the energy curve.
So let's fill in that
area as photoelectric.
Let's look at the other
extreme, pair production.
It scales with z
squared, so is that
going to be in the low
or the high z area?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHAEL SHORT: I
think still high,
just the bigger the z, the
bigger the cross-section,
right?
So we know that
pair production is
going to be in the high z area.
Now how about the energy?
It scales with
the log of energy,
but the energy is on the top.
So will a low or a high energy
give you more pair production?
High.
So pair production
is going to be here,
leaving everything else
for Compton scattering.
And if we jump back to
the start of last class,
we've reproduced from the
cross-sections the same sort
of plot that we saw
before just from looking
at the relative probabilities
of each effect, which
I think it's pretty cool.
We can now do that with some
basic physics knowledge.
Last thing I want to fill in
for Compton scattering is that
the Klein Nishina cross-section,
which is your differential
cross-section as a
function of omega,
combined with the probability
that you scatter into a certain
angle and a certain energy--
because there's a one-to-one
relationship--
ends up giving
you your d sigma c
over de, which is your energy
distribution of Compton recoil
electrons.
And that's directly what
leads to the shape right here,
where if you have,
let's say, 0.51 MeV,
relatively low energy, there's--
let's see.
What do I want to say here?
Yeah.
So as you go up in
higher and higher energy,
you get fewer and fewer
Compton electrons,
because like Jared was
saying, the probability
of a Compton
interaction does go down
with increasing energy, as
we kind of reasoned out.
But in addition, you
get relatively more
of these back scattered ones,
which is kind of interesting.
I have to think about that one.
But this is the typical
shape that you tend
to see for Compton scattering.
For high energy photons, you
get a Compton peak and then
a very long, shallow tail.
And as you go lower
and lower energy,
it starts to sort
of bounce back up.
And yeah, Luke?
AUDIENCE: When Compton
scattering happens,
are the electrons being
knocked off the atom?
MICHAEL SHORT: Oh, yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So how is that different from
the photoelectric effect?
MICHAEL SHORT: The
photoelectric effect
is an absorption
followed by an injection.
In Compton scattering, the
other photon is still intact.
It just loses energy,
gains wavelength.
But the energy of Compton
scattering is-- let's say,
for MeV photons, it's on the
order of hundreds of keV--
plenty to eject most of
the electrons from an atom.
So you always have
to think about are
you going to eject something?
Are you above the work function?
Work function for most atoms--
so we had a nice plot of that--
is in the eV range.
So chances are, yeah,
Compton scattering mostly
is going to be ejecting
electrons, too.
That's the whole reason
we can count them.
If there wasn't an
electron ejection,
there would be no electron
ionization cascade to count.
So there's some sort of
empirical or experimental proof
that it does happen.
And speaking of
experimental proof,
you can actually see that shape.
In this case, this is a spectrum
taken from two different gamma
sources together, a-- what is
it, 1.28 MeV and a 0.51 Mev.
And you can see that the
1.28 MeV, first of all,
has a way lower
number of counts,
showing that the
cross-section does,
indeed, decrease
with higher energy.
And it doesn't have-- well,
you can't really even see--
but it does not curving
back up, whereas this lower
energy Compton
photon is scattering
more often because
it's much higher,
and it's got that bump back
up at the really low energies.
So it's kind of
neat when the math
that we're looking at, if I jump
ahead to the cross-sections,
you can see that you'd
expect the Compton scattering
to decrease with energy.
And you look at an experimental
plot of two different energies,
and there you have
it, higher energy,
less total Compton scattering,
but different shape.
So any questions before
I move on to how you can
use them to design shielding?
So what we're getting
here, these cross-sections,
are probably better
known to some of you
as mass attenuation
coefficients, which
are simpler ways of
describing how many photons
in a narrow beam would
undergo some sort of process
and be removed from the beam.
And they get removed
exponentially
for the same sort of reason
for pretty much everything
in this class ends up being
an exponential, doesn't it?
Where if you have some
intensity of photons
or some change in
intensity that's
proportional to a change
in x in the initial--
let's see-- and some--
what is it, concept
of proportionality
like the cross-section,
or we'll call it now mu,
this mass attenuation
coefficient.
The answer to that ends up
being pretty much the same.
And it's this simple
exponential thing.
And the nice thing
is you don't have
to calculate all these different
cross-sections because they're
tabulated for you by NIST.
And that's one of the
links on the website,
on the learning modules website
that I want to show to you guys
now.
You can actually look up these
total summed cross-sections
for gamma ray
interactions as a function
of energy versus their mass
attenuation coefficient
in centimeters squared per gram.
The reason it's
in that unit is it
just tells you what
the material does.
It doesn't tell you how
much you have in the way.
And that's why I've rewritten
this exponential attenuation
formula with a rho on
the bottom and a rho
on the top, that rho being
the density of the material
because usually you can just
say, it's like i naught e
to the mu x.
But these are the things that
you'll look up in tables.
And these rhos right
here is whatever density
you have of your material.
So if you want to calculate
how much better cold water is
shielding than hot water because
of its change in density,
you can then look up
the value for water,
which I want to show
you how to do right now.
Back up to see the actual site.
So if you guys looked
right here, these--
what is it--
NIST tables of x-ray
absorption coefficients.
I'll show you how to
read through this table
now because you'll need it from
everything from problem set 5
to the rest of your life.
This is one of those places
you're going to go constantly
looking for nuclear data.
So you can either look
at elemental media
or compounds and mixtures,
water being one of them.
So let's go down
to water, liquid.
If you notice what's
actually given here
is this view over row.
So the nasty, what
is it, density
specific mass
attenuation coefficient.
In other words, it's a
cross-section, really.
It's a microscopic
cross-section.
I don't know why, in a
lot of these courses,
they're introduced separately
because they're the same thing.
They're interaction
probabilities.
And then that other
rho from the slides
just tells you how
much is in the way.
That rho times x just
tells you how much
water's in the way in
terms of how dense it is
and how thick your
water shield is.
So using these tables,
if you know, let's say,
you're sending in
one MeV photon,
so we look up 10 to the 0 MeV--
you then have this value,
this nice round value of 10
to the minus 1 centimeters
squared per gram.
You then multiply by
the density of the water
that you have multiplied by
the thickness of your water
shielding, and
you get the change
in intensity of the photons.
And let's do an example
calculation just
to make it a little more real.
So let's say we have a beam of
photons of intensity i naught.
And we're sending it
through a tank of water.
And the question is, do you want
to keep this water at 0 Celsius
or at 100 Celsius?
What's the difference in
shielding between freezing
and boiling liquid water?
Well, we can look that up.
And let's say we have to specify
an energy of the photons.
We'll call it 1 MeV photons.
So we can look up and say at
10 to the 0 MeV, we go over.
We get just about
0.1 mu over rho.
So mu over rho equals 0.1
centimeters squared per gram.
And now we can set up two
equations, one for 0 Celsius
and one for 100 Celsius.
So we'll say i at 0
C equals i naught.
E to the minus 0.1 times
rho at 0 Celsius times x.
Let's say we have, I don't
know, 10 centimeters of water.
So we'll just put a 10 in there.
That works out pretty well.
And then our i at 100C is
the same i naught times e
to the minus 0.1
times rho of water
at 100 times 10 centimeters.
And keep in mind
here, I made sure
that since my mu over rho units
are in centimeters squared
per gram, I'm putting
in x as 10 centimeters
because whatever is up
here in the exponential has
to be unitless.
That's a good check to see
why are my calculations off
by a factor of a billion?
Just check the units
in the exponential.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't the
value of 0.1 change
for your cross-section
[INAUDIBLE]??
MICHAEL SHORT: The
value of 0.1 will
change depending on the energy
of the incoming photons.
AUDIENCE: I mean,
for the density.
MICHAEL SHORT: Nope.
AUDIENCE: Density
changes, right?
MICHAEL SHORT: Density changes.
And that's what we account
for here with this rho.
So next up we have to look
up the densities of water
at 0 and 100 Celsius because
I don't actually know them.
So density of water at 0C--
oh, surprise,
surprise-- it's we'll
call it 1 gram per
centimeter cubed.
Now what is it at 100C?
Too close to tell.
Actually.
That's interesting.
At 0 it's a little lower.
AUDIENCE: No, I think that--
MICHAEL SHORT: I think
that site's wrong.
AUDIENCE: It's
definitely lower at 100C.
MICHAEL SHORT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I don't think
that second Google result is
talking about 100 degrees C.
MICHAEL SHORT: Let's
look at some steam tables
because this is a real
place to look for them.
So water is 100.
Celsius atmosphere is--
OK, we'll just see that.
I think they're down here.
Oh, the chalk's not letting
me use the touchpad.
That's kind of cool.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] water
at 100 degrees Celsius?
MICHAEL SHORT: Oh, there we go.
Yeah, I think I got it.
So what's the density
of saturated liquid?
0.958.
0.958 grams per
centimeter cubed.
Wow, I actually used
the last corner today.
Awesome.
So you can actually, then, go
ahead and calculate because--
I love how this
worked out, right?
0.1 in 10, cancel.
So we'll just do
e to the minus 1.
And we get that this i is
about 36.79% of the gammas
will be transmitted through
10 centimeters of water.
And here, e to the
power of negative 958,
we get 38.37% transmission.
So actually, about
2% more of the gamma
is will be transmitted
if the water is hot.
It's a neat little
calculation that you can do.
Now we've looked at a
really fine, or very small
magnitude example.
Folks came to me
yesterday saying
we want to design a new
type of medical x-ray apron
because we're worried that
people carrying around
all this lead, their
backs are hurting
and it's making surgeons'
lives difficult if they're
doing radioactive procedures.
Can we do any better?
Can they do any better?
What do you guys think?
Can you beat physics when it
comes to mass attenuation?
It's going to be
awfully difficult.
And the best weapon you have
is these mass attenuation
coefficients to look at
their relative values.
Now these, again, are in
centimeters squared per gram.
So this actually ranks
aluminum to uranium
in a sort of like
per atom basis.
It has nothing to do with
their higher densities, which
only help things.
This just tells
you how effective
each of these elements
is relatively at blocking
gammas of different energies.
Then, to get the total
amount of attenuation,
you multiply by the density.
Aluminum is pretty sparse.
Lead and uranium
are pretty dense.
There's not too many
ways around this problem.
In fact, I wouldn't
say that there's
a way around this problem.
The best thing
you can do is look
at the really only interesting
features on these curves.
Does anybody know why there's
those jagged edges there?
Well, let's take a
look at some trends.
For uranium, the jagged
edge is at about 110 keV.
For lead, it's like 80 keV.
For tin, it's probably
more like 50 keV.
It's decreasing with z.
Anyone remember what
sort of magnitude?
We've looked at things
like this before.
And if we're talking about
photon electron interactions,
what could be responsible for
those sudden jagged edges?
Well, we have talked
before about all sorts
of different decay
methods, including
those that can eject electrons
from different energy shells.
You're looking at the same
electron energy shells.
If you have a, let's say,
photoelectric capable photon
entering a calcium
nucleus-- and let's go look
at calcium as an example.
So I'll go to the
tables of coefficients.
I'm going to back up
to elemental media.
And I'm going to go to
calcium for a simple example.
Calcium has got this
jagged edge right here.
And if we draw a line down,
it is precisely 4 keV.
4 keV, I bet, is
going to be the k edge
energy, the energy of the most
inner bound calcium electron.
To find out, we can go
to the other NIST page
that I linked you guys to, the
NIST X-ray Transition Energy
Table.
And let's look at calcium.
Wow, this really doesn't work
with chalk on your fingers.
And let's look at
the k edge to check.
Lo and behold.
4.05 keV.
So what you're seeing here is
the photoelectric peak k edge
absorption.
What this says is at
energies below 4 keV,
you can't inject the
innermost electron.
You just don't
have enough energy.
As soon as you hit 4 keV,
those inner shell electrons
become accessible to you.
So the cross-section
suddenly jumps up
because you have more
electrons that you
can inject photoelectrically.
Beyond 100 keV or so,
there's no more jagged edges
because any photon above 100
keV can access pretty much
any electron in any
element, except maybe
the super heavy ones, and we
don't have data for them yet.
So then you might ask,
well, there's going
to be an L edge for calcium.
Where would that be?
Probably off this chart.
But you can look up
where it would be.
So we'll go to the NIST--
yeah.
So you had the right idea, Dan.
To the left, right?
Yeah.
Exactly.
So now let's look up the L edge.
So if I were to ask
you-- wow, it really
doesn't work with chalk.
OK, that's better.
So the L1 edge is down at
438 eV, which is indeed
off the scale for this graph.
This bottoms out at 1 keV.
But if I were to ask you to
draw the full mass attenuation
coefficient for
uranium, I'd expect
to see a k edge, an L edge,
an m edge, and an n edge
corresponding to shell
levels 1, 2, 3, and 4.
And where do you get that data?
You get it from here,
from this NIST databases.
Or you calculate it
one at a time using
that Rydberg formula, where
that n final goes to infinity.
So you can either calculate
them if you don't know.
Or if NIST doesn't have
them in the table--
and I don't think
they have the n edge--
wow, they go all the
way up to fermium.
Let's do uranium.
What do they go to?
Yep.
They don't have the
m or the n edge.
But you do know how to calculate
them, is with that formula.
And so if we were to
construct any old mass--
what is it, mass
coefficient-- good,
we have a little space left.
It's going to look
generally like this.
There's going to be a
photoelectric region.
Let's say that's
going to correspond
to our photoelectric
cross-section, which goes
way up with lower energies.
There's going to be a pair
production part, which
goes up with higher energies.
And there's going to be this
kind of decreasing Compton
cross-section.
And if you kind of
dance these curves,
you end up with a
shape like that,
which is just like all the other
mass attenuation coefficients
that you see.
So this is why
they take the shape
that they do if you add
up the cross-sections
for photoelectric effect,
Compton scattering, and pair
production, and you just kind
of bounce on top of those,
you end up with the mass
attenuation coefficient.
And the part that's
not shown here
is that this
photoelectric effect
will have some
jagged edges whenever
you hit an electron
energy transition level.
So it's five of.
Want to see if you guys
have any questions on photon
interactions with matter.
I know it's a lot to
throw at you at once,
but I'm going to be giving you
guys lots to calculate, to try
it out and to learn what's
going on from a more hands
on point of view.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you can't,
I guess, beat physics
by increasing
density of materials.
Is there a way to
slow down gammas?
MICHAEL SHORT: Is there a
way to slow down gammas?
AUDIENCE: Besides
relying on [INAUDIBLE]??
MICHAEL SHORT: Yeah.
So the question is, can
you slow down gammas
without putting
stuff in the way?
Well, then, what are you doing?
You've got a vacuum, right?
So-- hmm.
That's probably a deeper
question than I think.
So gammas, for example,
do have indices
of refraction and materials.
Gammas are just photons.
They're just really high energy.
And they do have
indices of refraction
that are usually around
one part per million,
or like 1.000001 or so.
So you can refract
or bend gamma.
Just not very well.
So the question is,
could you do something
to stop the gammas that
were maybe 10 feet away?
The answer is physics.
Not much you can do.
But if they're, like,
planetary levels away,
it's possible that you could
bend them away from an object,
just like you can bend visible
light away from something
closer up because
it's got a much
higher index of refraction.
Pretty crazy stuff.
Did you ever think of gamma ray
as having indices of refraction
and behaving like regular light?
It's just regular light.
It's just really
high energy light.
So any other questions on
the photon interactions
with matter?
Cool.